Hey, everybody. This is Eric with Phone Scoop.
We're just taking a quick look at the Samsung Galaxy tab 10.1,...
...a new Android tablet from Samsung.
It has a 10.1-inch screen...
...and has a little bit of a different design compared to the original.
On one side, we have the power key, a headset jack, and speakers.
Nothing along the bottom.
On the right, we've got more speakers and a SIM card slot,...
...and then on the right, we just have the volume toggle.
On the back we can see, I like this design.
It's kind of like a carbon fiber feel to it.
And the tab has a whopping 8-megapixel camera with a flash.
So, that is the Galaxy tab...
...and that is running Android 3.0 as we can see here.
We've got all sorts of different home screens.
And if we go to the apps, you can see the different applications.
It doesn't look like they have too many loaded on this device, though.
So, that is a quick look at the Samsung Galaxy tab 10.1.